almost four months since Las Vegas
shooting the worst in modern American
history still many mysteries and some
new developments in that case just two
days ago a lawyer for the Las Vegas
police indicated new charges could be
forthcoming odd since the only suspect
is dead
detectives though saying very little
Katherine Lombardo is an attorney
representing the victims of Las Vegas
she joins us long with Republican
congressman Scott Perry of Pennsylvania
who says he's got concerns about how
this is going first to you Katherine
what do you know yes we had court two
days ago it was the hearing for the
press where they have they asked the
court to release the search warrants the
affidavits and all of the returns which
means all of the evidence right and so
what we heard was quite shocking and
quite surprising now you have to
remember that sheriff Lombardo with the
Las Vegas Metro Police has told us at
his briefings that that Steven paddock
was the lone shooter he was the only
shooter however at the hearing we heard
two things one that there will be no
indictments coming for any murder or
shooting however they are investigating
other charges and crimes they wouldn't
say who they wouldn't say what the
entire courtroom took a gasp and looked
up and went silent for a second even the
judge reacted and the judge said
something like okay without telling me
who or what are you saying to me that
there will be other charges forthcoming
and the lawyer for the police said yes
there are other charges being
investigated the judge pressed him on
that and he said within 60 days so what
the judge did was she asked him for
further supplemental briefing to explain
to her what what that contains who it is
what it's about
you see we're asking in the press the
press is asking for the the documents
the evidence to be released since there
is no ongoing criminal investigation
that would that would be nice and answer
basic questions such as how was an
interior door locked inside the hotel
suite congressman you're the only member
of Congress I'm aware of who's taken a
public position asking questions about
this what are your questions well
I smell a rat like a lot of Americans do
nothing's adding up it's been four
months as you said we don't even the
man's dead they said he's a lone gunman
lone shooter yet we can't get the
autopsy results but even more troubling
than that recently I've been made aware
of what I believe to be credible
evidence or credible information
regarding potential terrorist
infiltration through the southern border
regarding this incident terrorist yes
sir
connections okay so what's the outline
of that with that well there could be
well let's let's face it
Isis twice before the attack Isis war in
the United States that they would attack
Las Vegas but they think in June and
August and then after the attack claimed
responsibility for times meanwhile the
local law enforcement investigative
services are telling us there is no
terrorist connection Lone Gunmen
something again something's not adding
well that's part of my confusion
Katherine can you just confirm that this
investigation is still being overseen by
state and local authorities rather than
federal that's right the FBI and the Las
Vegas Metro Police Department have been
conducting the investigation we've seen
no evidence of a terrorist attack and I
will ask with all due respect
congressman unless you have specific
evidence to back that up it seems a bit
irresponsible to make that allegation so
if you do or make that assertion if you
do have any evidence of that I'm asking
you right now to share it with us and
tell us what that is Michael all 22,000
people who are waiting and waiting and
waiting what's not the congressman
respond to that we've all been waiting
I'm waiting to like I said nothing adds
up but I'm just telling you I have
received what I feel to be and believed
to be credible evidence of a possible
terrorist Nexus and we're going to have
wait until until that situation develops
so so Catholic I'm not taking a position
on this either way but I want to get I
want to take that a little bit here if
that is your belief does Congress have a
role to play in this I don't know that
Congress has a role but I think who does
have a role is the National
Counterterrorism Center and if Isis
claims if Isis warns about an attack and
then an attack occurs and then claims
responsibility after the fact right it
seems to me
that at a minimum they should have some
portion of the investigation
- clearly debunk that claim and yet it
hasn't had of time but we will be taking
a press conference tomorrow out of Las
Vegas by the investigators hopefully
we're going to learn more and I hope we
speak to both you again on the Statue
both very much